سام لاغرون ، محرر
أخبار المعهد البحري الأمريكي ينضم إلي الآن ، حسنًا ،
لذا سنقوم بوضع نسخة احتياطية لصورة القمر الصناعي
أخبرنا بما ننظر
إليه ، هذا
ما تراه يخبرك أن
هناك  مشروع دولفين في مكانه
حتى ترى مدخل المرفأ
يوجد جدار بحري من نوع ما على
الجانب الشمالي لذلك ترى هذين
المربعين
محاطين
بتلك العوامات الصفراء أو البرتقالية وهما
أقلام دولفين لا لبس
فيها وهي
من نفس النوع  أن السوفيتات
والروس والأوكرانيين عندما
استخدموا الدلافين الروسية لفترة وجيزة
لسنوات وسنوات ، وإذا
كنت تعرف ما تبحث عنه ،
فلا يبدو أنه أي شيء آخر ،
فراجع كيف يبدو الروس
تستخدم البحرية أو البحرية الدلافين المدربة ،
فما الذي يمكنهم فعله وما لم تكن الآلات أو البشر
قد تطورت جيدًا وأن تكون الدلافين جهازًا
مدهشًا جدًا
في
أدمغتهم ، لذلك لم يكن البشر
قادرين على الميكانيكا
اكتشاف الأشياء بسهولة أو إلكترونيًا ، وكذلك يمكن للدلافين
استخدام مواهبهم التي
تطورت على مدى أه الوقت هم أيضًا
سباحون رائعون يمكنهم السباحة
أربع أو خمس مرات
أسرع مما يمكن لأي شخص ، وهذا يعني
أنه يمكنهم العثور عليها  الأشياء في الماء
وإخبار الناس عنها أه بسرعة أه
أسرع مما يمكن للسباح البشري أن
يصح ، لذا إذا كان بإمكانك التوسع في
ذلك مثل ما يتم تدريبهم بالضبط
على فعل ما يفعلونه
أه للروس ،
لذا فإن
الدلافين بشكل عام أم  وظيفتان
رئيسيتان أه في القوات البحرية حول العالم
إحداهما
أه إيجاد ألغام محيطية أو ألغام بحرية
يصعب اكتشافها باستخدام ذلك
السونار الخاص الذي لديهم أه
الآخر هو إيجاد أه عمليات خاصة
سباحين أو رجال ضفادع و  لذا ، إذا فكرت في
سيفاستوبول حيث قامت البحرية الروسية
بإعداد سفنها الحربية في الوقت الحالي ،
فقد يكون
هدفًا سهلاً حقًا لسباح مصمم
ليأتي ويضع ذهنًا تحت الماء في ذلك ،
ولكن ما يمكن أن يفعله الدلفين  هل
يمكن تدريبه على البحث عن السباحين
وبسبب مجموعته
الواسعة من الأدوات الحسية ، يمكنه
العثور عليه بسهولة وبسرعة كبيرة
، ثم يخبر أحد المساعدين البشريين على الأرض
أنه يوجد شيء هنا
ربما يجب عليك التحقق منه